[Music]
anyways what is this from the subreddit
submit your most effed up dating
flirting stories bad first dates or
relationship advice below you can link
when did we post this three months ago
yeah you guys never wanted to talk about
it yeah I thought it would be fun though
that's fair I went on a date with a guy
first mistake
I went on a DAT with a guy and
everything was fine well then what's the
problem until we were sitting in my car
and somehow got on the topic of
dinosaurs I mentioned how as a kid I
liked them and this giant Dinosaur book
and he goes no way so did I that's wild
then suddenly got really quiet and was
staring out into the distance I asked if
he was okay and I suddenly hear sniffles
and he turns to me in tears and says
I've just wow I just never met someone
with the same interests and he proceeded
to sob for like 10 minutes mind you we
were both 20 at the time I couldn't
console him so I just sat there in
silence until he got it together what
made it even more crazy is he wiped his
tears and tried to tell me a story about
how tongue almost got split so we could
make
out and this guy didn't kill
you
huh yeah just
general thoughts if a person breaks down
crying next to me about a dinosaur
book I
would maybe within the first three
minutes
go hey I think you need to
leave
and that's just for
safety you
know get him
out that's an emotionally unstable
person referencing a book about
dinosaurs and he starts
crying I don't know that sounds like
Master manipulation to me he's trying to
draw you
in
yeah or you completely made this up and
you're [__]
alone
this one looks fun I female 20 met this
guy male 29 on Bumble and went to his
place to hook up
pause when people say hook
up it makes me laugh because I have this
juvenile reference of that phrase
hookup because people would say that in
middle school and they refer to people
making out and I've never been able to
advance my initial thought of the word
hookup so I basically read these
sentences like I met this guy on Bumble
and we set a time to
[Music]
kiss but no we know what this means they
uh they went to this place to suck and
[__] we vibed so a week
later asked him to come to my
place to or on
this guy seems so genuinely nice I'm
usually a very good judge of character
but basically when he arrived at my
place he had a suitcase with him he said
it's because he's moving Apartments
tomorrow come on and so he thought he'd
just go straight there from my place we
have a good night having sex and
drinking beer I start asking him about
his family and his parents and he goes
completely silent then I ask him about
his job and he starts to get kind of
annoyed so I put on a movie
we were watching a crime
movie so I jokingly asked him if he's
ever been arrested this is going good
he's had about 15 beers at this point
and starts confessing firstly the
suitcase is because he's literally
moving back to Wales the next day and he
wants me to take him to the airport he
didn't tell me because he didn't think
I'd have sex with
him that's not
funny if I knew he sorry he didn't tell
me because he didn't think I'd have sex
with him if I knew he was leaving the
country secondly turns out he makes his
money through illegal fights in Thailand
thirdly he has been arrested before he
was in prison for five years for assault
with a deadly weapon and assaulting a
police officer let me pause here as an
Australian you've clearly never dated an
American
okay you
know you should be concerned if the man
you're dating hasn't been to prison and
hadn't hasn't had a charge a charge for
assault with a dead deadly weapon in
America you should be concerned and last
but certainly not least he got touchy
when I asked about his parents that's a
weird
reflex tell me about your
[Music]
mom
asked about his parents because when he
was 11 years old his dad murdered his
mom and then burn their house down with
the two of them
inside what the
[__] I dropped this psycho
bro this psycho gimm bro at the airport
the next day and he gave me chicken
breasts and white rice as a Parting Gift
I'm
vegetarian that's what he feeds his
Fighters
dude
okay very bold to say you're a good
judge of character at 20 years
old really bold all right let's
continue this is a good time
waster JK
JK we'll get one more you know these are
these are always you know it's hard to
believe these here we
go first date with a girl a while back
already
lying we went out for a few drinks and
it was all going good and then she got
incredibly drunk
like parallactic paraly like paraly
paralytic paralytic
yeah incredibly drunk like
paralytic I was asking for her phone to
call a friend or someone who could come
pick her up she wouldn't tell me where
she lived why how do you guys get
involved with these
people what are you on like you you all
keep meeting
spies who's your family what's your
background don't ask
questions how do you all manage to have
sex with
007 I was asking for her phone to call a
friend or someone who come pick her up
she wouldn't tell me where she lived or
any of her friends names so I could even
take her home then passed out in a train
station the security guards kept telling
me the train station had closed and
wouldn't help me at all so I had to put
her in a taxi and go to my house where I
was going to tell I was going to let her
sober up on the sofa and would then get
her home as we got got to mine uh she
was completely unconscious and I
couldn't get her out of the taxi luckily
some friends were uh walking home from a
local pub and bumped into me managed to
get her on my sofa with a bin to be sick
in as we figured out uh what to do one
of my friends went into the kitchen
while I was taking a piss my dog was
frightened and bit him so I had a friend
bleeding in my kitchen and a girl who I
hardly know uh throwing up on my sofa
after about an hour she came around and
rang her friend so I booked a taxi to uh
excuse me so I booked a taxi to take her
there and then back home cost me around
200 pound in taxis my mate who got bit
was fine thankfully but truly the worst
first date of my life hands down the
worst dating experience I've ever had
forgot to say this is technically my
first date ever I was in a long-term
relationship from school and this was
the first date after becoming single for
the first time in eight
years dude you have a an amazing career
in smut
writing this is such a great
story